if you don't have a compass um number
one that'll be okay because um
you can do this without a compass i'll
show you both ways but number two even
if you do have a compass
unfortunately these aren't the greatest
compasses so if you start using it
you're like
i'm not getting enough accuracy with
this then just just ditch it it's we'll
still be able to do it anyway
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to start by drawing a square
now i've thought about this i've given
it a go on an a4 page if you've got an
a4 book
you should be able to draw and make sure
it's on like one side of the page don't
draw it right in the middle
you should be able to draw a 10
centimeter square on an a4 page you
should be able to fit that and we'll be
able to construct the rest out of it
if you do not have an a4 page yours will
obviously need to be
well i don't know roughly something like
that
okay the bigger you can make it the
better but i'm going off measurements of
kind of like 10 centimetres
now draw your 10 centimeter square
okay there you go and you don't have to
mark this in but
all that equal size there okay
so yeah yeah so draw this on one side
because what's going to happen in a
second
is we're going to construct extra things
on the side right
so yeah do a landscape
it doesn't matter which side you'll
you'll just you'll decide which way
like i'm going to construct it this way
because that's where i have space but
you'll construct it in a different
direction that's no big deal
right now um remember i said uh
for me this is 10 centimeters across the
bottom okay so i want to mark on this
bottom side for me
i'm going to mark out the midpoint of
this side down here so that's going to
be five centimeters long for me
if your square is a bit smaller or
bigger you get the idea
okay so suppose i get that
that's my midpoint
right now with your ruler i want you to
join up this midpoint
okay with the corner of the square
that's opposite
in the direction you want to construct
okay so for example if you're like me
and i have no space to draw more stuff
over here i'm not going to draw this way
right so i want you with your ruler draw
yourself a dotted line up there
so there you go now if you want to do
this with a compass here's what you're
going to do
okay you're going to place your compass
point on that midpoint over there
okay and stretch it out so that the
other end of the compass
right just like my two arms is going to
be on that corner okay so there you go
you're going to have this this distance
measured out
now with your compass that long if
you've got a compass if you don't have
one i'll show you how to do this in a
second
i want you to draw an arc it's going to
look like this it's going to come down
like this okay so in some ways this is
like the center of a circle
this is the radius okay so it'll look
something like this
roughly is that okay so i've started
from here and i've just drawn the arc
down
it's important that it goes all the way
past the side of the square
okay now if you do not have a ruler
that's sorry a compass that's okay
instead what i want you to do
is measure out that length and measure
it very carefully
just write down what you get that
measurement to be
now again coming back to the compass
you've drawn this arc
right you're going to have that meet up
with
remember this side which has the
midpoint on it i want you to extend it
along
extend it along okay so it's going to
look like this
so that's going straight along and
you'll see your
new your arc and your new extended path
they will meet
tada there okay are you following so far
now if you didn't have a compass instead
of um doing that arc
and finding that point by the
intersection what you're going to do is
just take that whatever you measured
and take whatever you measured and
because this should be
the arc of a circle and here's the
center right yeah this distance will be
the same as this distance right they're
both radii of the same circle
okay that's all the compass is achieving
it's just giving us the same distance
without needing to
measure it out so
one way or another either by putting
through that arc
or measuring out this distance now
you've got this new point
right well this new point down here is
going to
form um one of the it's going to be one
of the corners of this of a new
rectangle we're going to draw
so from this extended line up here
through our new point okay we're going
to draw a line straight up perpendicular
like this
okay you see it's going up there's my
there's my right angle in there
to show you that this is going to be a
rectangle in a second okay
and then what i want you to do is join
up
that corner at the top
right and now we have a shape i need
whoa
so far hopefully you've mostly caught up
with me
we have a new rectangle okay it goes all
the way around like this
and if you've got another color as well
maybe you want a highlighter too because
you'll have a few construction lines
flying around
so to highlight it here's my rectangle
okay now
here is what i would like to suggest to
you this rectangle
is one that we just constructed by by
use of this compass one to measurement
okay
i put to you that this rectangle is
beautiful
i think it has a quality about it uh
it's a very
important rectangle it's all about the
proportions
this construction that you did gave it
certain proportions
okay this rectangle is so beautiful even
if you don't look at it and you say oh
wow
that's not bad looking okay um people
the world over
recognize the beauty of this rectangle
i'll give you some examples
almost every iconic piece of
architecture
almost everyone okay for instance the
taj mahal if you don't recognize it okay
uh in which case you need some history
lessons the taj mahal is constructed
out of these rectangles right you've got
three you may be able to just make it
out there's three of them there's one
there
that's the big one okay and then these
two on the sides
adjoin it well it sort of goes all
around it's symmetrical okay the taj
mahal
made out of golden rectangles it's not
the only one another famous
example let's see if i can do it like
this
is in greece ancient greece in
particular this is anyone know what's
called
saturn it's the parthenon the parthenon
right
now you can think about this two
different ways you can look at the front
front i know it's offered a perspective
angle but you can still kind of make out
in that front you've got golden
rectangles everywhere
not only that but the reason why i
picked this shot is because if you look
from
from the top down if you had an aerial
view right
this leg to this length these sides
being perpendicular right
guess what it looks like from the top
okay
i can keep going um go to paris
go to france okay that's that's not your
name cathedral okay
again built out of golden rectangles
right
rectangles with the golden ratio there's
hundreds of them there
okay i could overlay it but then you
wouldn't see not
anymore okay uh one more
you're like wait a second that's not
even
a rectangle right true that's the great
pyramid
in giza okay um you know it's the only
it's the only surviving of the wonders
of the world right the ancient wonders
of the world
but the golden ratio is nestled in there
just like it's nestled
in here okay now let's actually find out
what this thing
is let's not just draw it okay let's
find out what is this number this ratio
that's underpinning this okay